Joanne is with us and Johanna is going
to start off this hour from Maryland hi
Joanne welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave it's such a pleasure speaking
with you is such an honor thank you so
much sure when I get to the point um so
i had a small online business account i
had a small business last year
and I opened a account with a major bank
which I had since closed last year also
but during the time when I opened a
checking account also opened a credit
card which I used one time and purchase
a small you know this small item for
less than $100 I had painted off and
recently this year in April I got a
statement from the bank stating that I
owe them money for late charges and I
called them and tried to resolve this
issue and come to find out the payments
that I made last year were reversed by
them but they didn't notify me or give
me a call to let me know that they had
done that until I called them this April
well my payments reversed
and that's the reason why I was calling
them because there was no explanation
and every time I called them I've been
transferred to your multiple department
and none of them could tell me exactly
why they were reversed
what did you you paid a payment out of
your checking account correct out of my
savings account or your savings account
okay do you not go back and look at your
savings account and make sure that
balances well when I look at my account
it showed that it posted on both
accounts in my savings and in the credit
card statement and then three weeks
three weeks or a few weeks after that
they came back and told me that no we
credited your account back we would list
the payment but there was no explanation
as to why they did it and I was a year
ago it was last year okay so you knew it
though at the time that it came back
right no I just found out actually this
April and you don't look at your
checking account
to see a reversed charge but once a year
I you know I did not that was my problem
I guess that was my issue I did not look
at that account and since I had not been
happy with their customer service I
actually closed my account with them and
then they just sent me a statement this
April and I shall I spoke so how much
did I say you owe them now it's not much
it's only sixty dollars and 55 cents
sixty dollars on a charge that's under a
hundred yeah so those were actually late
fees for a year that I owe them for you
yes that's what they told me that I owe
and you're not been getting statements
from them saying you owe money well this
is the first time actually I look at the
same Oh actually an April those was the
first time I receive a speaking and
showing I had okay here's what you need
to do what company is this Bank of
America of course it is yeah that's what
ok so you've learned two lessons well if
you're smart one is you don't deal with
mega banks like Bank of America because
they're stupid
yeah the second lesson you've learned is
you have to watch and take care of
business better than you have been you
didn't open your credit card statements
for a year and you didn't look at your
savings account to see that the charges
have been reversed for a year that's not
taking care of business well that's
that's true and I understand that and
this cost you so this is what's called
$60.00 in stupid tags not looking at
your statements or opening them for a
year stupid so it cost you 60 bucks
mm-hmm should I be complaining about
this in the future what if I mean my
behind is it's going to show that you
have late payments on your credit bureau
report for a year
well I guess that wouldn't matter cuz
I'm trying to follow your step that
doesn't matter much but here's the thing
when I do something stupid and it costs
me money I call that stupid tax I have
paid a lot of stupid tax and the good
rule about stupid tax is never pay the
same one twice okay okay and there you
pay you're paying a
$60 which is a fairly light tax I mean
that's not too bad for not opening your
statements and not watching over your
business well and for doing business
with companies like Bank of America so
you learn two lessons both for 60 bucks
that's a bargain
that's a bargain right the check closed
the account be done with these idiots
because you're technically legally over
the money
I don't know why they would reverse a
perfectly good payment but what the heck
do it anyway you know they're it's Bank
of America they're stupid they just they
have no soul and the best thing to do is
not do business with them so yeah yeah
that's what I would do if I were in your
shoes you know it's kind of like this
guy's it's the same thing I'd I never
did this but I had a whole bunch of
friends that did this because I grew up
in the real estate business so I knew
better but a lot of people when you're
leaving a rental property they just move
off
well that lease is up and you just move
off and you go well I want my deposit
back because the property was left in
good condition don't do that that's
gonna cost you your deposit a bunch of
times with a bunch of landlords because
they're gonna come in and NIT pick apart
the condition of the property and keep
your deposit instead you should always
meet the management company of the
landlord or whoever on the site after
you have moved out and get a signed
agreement that the property is in as to
what as to the condition the property is
in and the amount of the deposit that's
going to be returned returned and the
fact that you've completed the lease
legally and in full
you should check into a property when
you lease it you should check out of a
property when you lease it with
documentation when you don't you're
gonna end up paying stupid tax law
repaid to rent moved off I can't tell
you any times I've heard that and then
they go well we had to replace the
carpet you know the corporate was fine
when I left and we're taking that out of
your deposit because there was no
agreement as to the condition of the
property when you move that's the same
kind of thing you have to open your mail
you have to do look at your biz
this you can't stick your head in the
sand and ignore stuff you can't have but
do business in transactions as an adult
out here walking around and end up
anything but losing money as a result
and that's what happened to her that's
what happened those people I'm talking
about I've done stuff exactly like that
- can't think of an example off the top
of my head right now but believe me I've
been as stupid as any of you have ever
been and it still catches up with you
and still bite you and I still pay
stupid tax that's the thing